what is happening raging nation I'm Greg
Alva I'm John Humphrey my and he goes
now he goes next I'm insane ready full
name is Tara Eriksen Tara Eriksen for
the turrets and shadows here yes you
said at Ericsson Jim Tara Ericsson show
over at patreon one of our perks is that
whatever video you request will
definitely check out gareth hood is one
of our top pleasures and he has finally
after four months asked for a video for
us to check out so here we are gareth
just video and also i didn't get a
chance to do this for Garrett's son on
the flash video like yes like totally
forgot shoutout to jared son Yusuf
you're a beautiful boy I remembered when
Jared showed us a video you check it out
a video we did and I was so touching
commit my heart melt Yousef you are the
most adorable thing in the world more
adorable than any other child out there
I don't rave too much about a child like
this Ken yeah the beauty of a child is a
little creepy to rave about a lot of but
you know you could play up other stuff
too yeah there are sort of people that
ruin Kyle oh yeah vigilance will SIA
will sigh close-up magic act with cards
in coins
oh yeah magic hello Allen I like it
thank you
and what's your name my name is will and
how do you I'm 33 okay
do you have any kids no yes do you have
any pet I have a dog and a cat oh that's
good what are they go what is it is
bluffington
okay well why America Coachella because
this is my dream
I'm hoping this would be a turning point
in my life I really want to make it
happen for my family
[Music]
all I can notice you guys that wonderful
I've never done there for anybody I just
created for the show are you serious
[Applause]
well okay we'll good luck is not wait to
see this
thank you nobody gonna do what's good do
you mMmmm this all-star judge battle man
I know Howie Howie Mandel but like
flowers because they remind me of how
beautiful life is while also very
fragile he's going to mess my mind and
that's why every second counts
in the grand scheme of things life
happens in blink of an eye so for the
next to moment don't blink okay I'm into
the Magic Castle
[Music]
due to me well
[Music]
no that's not real
that was right like a jump cut maybe he
has like magnificent rate maybe there's
nothing special that is
[Music]
[Applause]
America runs on will
Wow Thanks Tyra Banks yeah
you're still so pretty you know when
that search started off we've all been
in the Magic Castle right yeah when that
trick started off if you guys don't know
what the Magic Castle is its paces giant
castle we're like a bunch of rooms with
a bunch of different magicians
performing awesome magic tricks imagine
Harry Potter but much smaller and a lot
more people going I think I know you
so it's so in in that damn crowd yeah
I don't know okay you know I saw all
those tricks coming the hammer there was
therefore there that ah don't be like
the guy as your magic oh not so that
you're started going with the coins and
so I'm like okay yeah I've seen that
trick done before coin magic any when it
starts going super fast I have never
seen that done before that was true
there was one moment over look like a
jump I agree when it went from before
and then he took away it just watch yeah
and I'm like you cut into that let's
watch that part again you cut into it
I mean it look they move so so you'd be
like back at the table yeah but I don't
think it's acted that around it yeah
yeah that like what's going on things so
they didn't cut his hands up in cut his
hands that right yeah right there looks
like a jump cut yeah I don't know I
don't know I can't tell there's got to
be some up at that table there's got to
be some kind of like I don't want to say
no that was not magic sorcery
I like Barnum Garner was a-standin it's
a Magic Flute all educated they were not
magic well it's not what magical change
table guys he found a magical table will
die in his amazing table one of the
devices could be magic Gareth thanks for
setting up that video that was for
brightening up our day now
not because now I'm really messed up up
here you've broken our perception of
space-time visit thanks man
and I'm sad that I also don't have a
magic table you can you can get one I'll
be annoying yeah you can II steal one
from a wizard imagine just trying to
grab your cup and it just keeps like
changing spot I'd write your dinner I'd
try to grab my cup oh ha ha ha ha ha I'm
also thirsty yeah I understand ha ha
magic [ __ ] you really has an on and off
switch hey Gareth love you Yussef
another no morning Garrett I have lots
of criticisms to this day all right
literally his act bro with Gareth use if
you guys are beautiful
well it could have been funnier
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
dad John Hill free on Twitter and
Instagram better Erickson I'm Tara
Ericsson YouTube channel please sir
Erickson on Twitter and Instagram and
patreon all across our boards bye